In 2001 was important film for me because I didn't understand it. When I thought
Our dad had taken me.
And I was so frustrated by the movie and kind of hated the movie.
When I first thought it was a good, what is it? Stupid blood.
Thing.
Stupid. And I was like, I didn't get the, but it was a black thing. And he said,
Oh, that's a symbol. And I kind of like knew what the word was,
but then suddenly I had a visual understanding of what the word was.
It's like a symbol of what? And he said, Oh,
it's kind of like a similar for the consciousness of God.
I didn't even understand what that meant, but it sounded amazing.
And so then I asked him to take me back to see it again. And I thought again,
and then whenever I saw the symbol, I thought of like, God,
and it made more sense to me.
And this was like a strange phenomenon that you could suddenly look at something
and then have different eyes and see it again and understand it in a
completely different way.
The answer is out there looking for you.
Let me tell you why you're here. You're here because you know something,
what do you know? You can't explain, but you feel it.
You felt it your entire life. You don't know what it is, but it's there. It is.
This feeling that has brought you to me.
Do you know what I'm talking about?
They'll make her a Lily white Koski of formerly known as Andy came out publicly
as transgender on Tuesday, something her sister and creative partner,
Lana did a years before theirs.
Being cast back on. As in my work, through the lens of our transmits,
it seems that you've been living.
Two lives.
I finally came out to my family. When I told my mom what was going on,
she jumped on a plane immediately. There was this big tear,
soaked baptism, and she confessed that.
She'd been afraid to come here to arrive and grieve the loss of her
son far from it. But when she arrived,
she found it wasn't so much as a death, as it was a discovery, just thought,
um.
You were a guy. Most guys do.
That. There was this other part of me and unseen part.
She felt it was like a gift because now she could get to know.
No that part of one of these lives has a future.
A mirror boy mirrors can be tough for all of us,
but trans people can be.
Like everyone else. You were born into,
born into a prison that you cannot smell or taste or touch a
prison for you.
I kept this strange relentless vigil staring in the mirror for
hours afraid of what one day I might see. You have to see it for yourself.
The enduring power of the Cinderella myth is this catharsis,
this fitting of a slipper representing this intersection of who we see in the
looking glass with who we want to be.
Your appearance now is what we call residual. Self-image.
It is the mental projection of your digital self.
I'm going to show them a world without you,
a world without rules and controls without borders or boundaries, a world.
Anything is possible.
Here. One checked box,
one letter and M granted me access to legal,
social financial privilege while another box, another letter,
and AF denied them to me early on. I am told to get in line after a morning,
bell girls in one line boys and the other.
I walked past the girls feeling this strange,
powerful gravity of association.
As soon as I look towards the other line though,
I feel a feeling of differentiation that confuses me.
I don't belong there either. I stop in between them.
Where we go from there. It's a choice. I leave to you.
When I see the headlight, I take off my backpack and I put it on the bench.
As the note in front of it,
I try not to think of anything but jumping as the train comes.
Your death. Goodbye, Mr. Henderson.
We went to dinner.
I dressed as feminine as I could wanting to be seen by strangers as Lana hoping
our waiters were not coming, sir, or.
[Inaudible].
I am Lynn. This is my daughter, Lana, the waitress smile and said, wow.
She looks just like you.
[Inaudible].
Of all the things I love about my hair
high on the list is the way children stare at it with fascination
and delight.
I can sometimes see their imagination bright in their eyes,
recalibrating the possible.
It is my hope that a symbol like pink dreads might help them
understand.
Normal is something that does not have to be defined for you,
but rather by you. I am here because when I was young,
I wanted very badly to be a writer. I wanted to be a filmmaker,
but I couldn't find anyone liked me in the world.
And it felt that my dreams were for closed.
Simply my gender was less typical than others.
It's an excellent reminder that art is never static.
And while the ideas of identity and transformation are critical components in
our work, the bedrock that all ideas rest upon his love.
I know I am also here because of the strength and courage and love that I am
blessed to receive from my wife, my family, and my friends. And in this way,
I hope to offer their love in the form of mind materiality.
So this world that we imagine in this room,
it might be used to gain access to other rooms, to other worlds.
Previously.
He told me I wasn't really looking for him. I was looking for an answer.
It's the question that drives us.
You know, the question just doesn't.